welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensed
and it really is going to get a bit
uncensored here but only fans has become
a digital phenomenon there's 190 million
users and three million so-called
creators who mostly use the space to
upload x-rated photographs and videos of
themselves for their subscribers and
it's big business very big business
raking in five billion dollars a year
Well Ellie Brooke who makes six to seven
figures per month on the site describes
it as empowering but after years of
fighting back against the objective use
of women in newspapers magazines and his
cheerleaders and Sport isn't it just
well a bit of a backward step well
joining me now is only fans greater L
Brooke I didn't ask and then got it
wrong didn't I I'm the host of The Blair
White Project Blair white over in the
state so welcome to both of you all
right l now tell me about yourself yeah
what were you before you did this
um I was a law student
um and now I'm a teacher a university
yeah a university in your Southampton so
did you graduate or no no I dropped out
to do any fans because I was making a
lot of money so I was like why am I
doing speaking studying to be a lot a
lawyer yes and then you start doing only
fans while you're at University yes what
made you get into it because I saw how
much money other people were earning and
I was thinking hey I can do this too and
then turns out I'm pretty good at
getting my clothes off and I was like
this is a career for me okay look I've
nothing against you I don't I'm not
taking a moral view here right you can
do it the hell you like it's legal uh
I'm just disappointed that someone like
you've obviously got a great brain yeah
training to be a law student at
University
decides to pack it all in to just take
your clothes off for perfect strangers
on only fans why because I wouldn't have
made loads of money as a solicitor
anyway like I would have earned money
yes but I earned that in two weeks now
and I earned that throughout you how
much do you make I mean how much money
do you want I earn a lot how much do you
make maybe like double that
well I won't get into what I am but what
do you earn I I earn a lot of money well
I don't want to give a specific number
but I'm 0.01 on any phone so I'm as top
as it gets what does that mean it means
you are the best of the best 0.01 best
to the best of what any fans creditors
in monetary terms why are you so good
because I'm really good looking
right an original we're certainly not
shy are you no I know I'm good at what I
do I'm not gonna harangue you for being
cocky because that would be ridiculous
coming from me but um all right well let
me go to to Blair here I mean Blair look
on the face of it isn't this really what
feminist empowerment's all about a woman
in control of her body doing what she
wants with it making a huge amount of
money isn't it entirely down to L what
she decides to do
it absolutely is up to Al to do whatever
she wants to do in her professional
career and I don't have any issue with
adults doing what they want entering sex
work however unfortunately I think the
way in which only fans is often
discussed in public makes it out to be
this quick Get Rich scheme it reeks of a
pyramid scheme and oftentimes young
girls find themselves following this
Fool's Gold Rush and not really
understanding the consequences of it so
here's some information that I feel like
young girls should arm themselves with
the average registered only fans Creator
makes only 180 a month that's the
average so we're not discussing l in
that obviously but that is the average
making about 2500 a month puts you in
the top one percent which adds up to 15
an hour which is the same or less than
McDonald's pays so oftentimes these
young girls find themselves you know
entering sex work thinking that it's
going to be financially you know
beneficial for them and they end up
making less than a fast food worker but
they still take on the entire stigma of
being involved in sex work and
oftentimes you can't find employment
after afterwards so my only issue is
people doing these things without having
you know themselves armed with the
information and I think everyone should
know what them together yeah you make
some good points I mean what do your
family think of this I mean they must be
incredibly disappointed surely that you
backed in a potentially really
successful career as a lawyer to do this
yes my dad is dead and my mum is on my
payroll my family your mom's on your
payroll my mother's on my payroll
um admin what does that mean it's just
behind the scenes work she doesn't do
anything rude or anything so she loves
you doing this well she doesn't praise
it at the pub like woohoo my daughter
does only fans but she's supportive she
knows that I'm over 18 I can do what the
hell I want and she knows that you know
her views can't like impact my life what
is she gonna do you're grounded because
you do only fans like what the hell is
2023 people do what the hell they want
no no don't get me wrong I totally
subscribe to that and we the show you
subscribe uh I just subscribe to you but
uh
um I haven't bestowed you that honor yet
no but the look I think this Show's
called uncensored you can do it earlier
later I don't care but I'm just curious
about you being someone who embarked on
a a law career was obviously very bright
went to University packed it in just for
money to be effectively an online
stripper I mean that's what you do right
yeah way worse than an online stripper
but uh what do you mean
online strippers just you know naked I
do things that are way more grotesque
which is pornography pornography
anything but it's all then what I want
to do and I absolutely love it and I'm
really good at it you know I could be a
good lawyer yes but also am I good at
doing other things on video on camera
how would you feel when you want to have
kids yourself well I mean that's I I
don't really want kids right now how old
are you 25 right so you will do some
stage probably right when you do you're
going to be proud that you have your
little ones and they look at you and go
didn't you want to be a lawyer mommy
what happened yeah you go yeah but look
at all my stuff they can cry on a
Ferrari
you see there will be I know there will
be people watching this younger people
cheering you on yeah girl you go well
and then other people
going what what do you what are you
sounding like you sound awful good task
it's like why why go down this road
you've obviously you could be doing
something so much better for the world
than this couldn't you no I've been so
um like sexually open since I was at
school and if you met anyone in my year
group they would be like you were
absolutely made to do this and I think
if you put your mind to something then
you can absolutely achieve it like look
at me with a little bit of good looks
and hard work you can become a
millionaire Blair look you know play
Devil's Advocate Blair I mean look you
know we I saw you rolling your eyes but
the bottom line is she's making millions
doing what she enjoys doing
um
very popular I mean who are we to be too
prudish about it frankly
it's nothing to do with Albert I think
it's important to state that it's not
just about having good looks and a
little bit of work ethic because
oftentimes like I just said you could be
incredibly good looking at only fans and
only bring in 180 a month and still take
on the entire stigma doing sex work so
while it's important to you know say
that everyone can do what they want we
do have to acknowledge that L is the
exception not the rule and oftentimes
these young girls sometimes on their
18th birthday are being misled into
joining the site that completely
demolishes any prospects of future
employment for them and often
statistically any chances of having
relationships a lot of only fans girls
are actually regretting being on the
website coming forward and saying they
can't get a job now and they can't get a
date and they never even made the money
to justify doing so happy for L but
that's the exception okay yeah let me
ask you on that point I mean do you have
a a man or no you want a man no I'm
single at the moment but can I just
point out that people fail at jobs all
the time like just because you didn't
make it as an actor do you regret being
an actor like so many companies go
Brusque bus and like
if you've done porn
sorry
I said but if you fail at McDonald's you
didn't flip a burger correctly for a
customer if you fail at only fans
there's videos and pictures of you
having sex or being naked on the
internet forever you make that choice
it's not like loads of people fail no I
know
information but you should be armed with
the information is what I'm saying you
don't need to say that honestly we gotta
rabbit level what does it say about
Society where a bright young woman like
you yeah right decides to abandon a
career in a fantastic career as a lawyer
to do this just because it's making you
money online what does it say about the
way Society is gone
that I'm successful no matter what I do
I'd be successful as anything and just
be pretty proud of you are you proud of
it though yeah of course I am of course
I am more than you would be the only
fans I box I have a big social presence
I have everything and only fans was my
gateway to become this influencer that I
am now and I wanted to be an influencer
really who wants any any maybe not any
fans but anyway
I had pretty shallow people I've got to
be honest because they think they're a
great influencing on people but most of
them aren't they're a bad influence I
feel like now you've been to platforms
you're kind of an influencer really yeah
I don't know just you could have any
views online or post them on your own
influence that's true that that has me
as you that's true but I see myself I
see myself as a journalist it was a
career I always wanted to do you would
have been a lawyer if you hadn't taken
this path I reckon I'll interview again
in 15 years yeah and you'll say you know
what peers you were right I'll pick you
up in my Bugatti okay well it'll be one
or the other thank you for coming in
I'll appreciate it and thank you Blair
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much